hey guys Andy Joe here from honest
trailers we love that you love honest
trailers we love them too but you know
what show we really love to make roasts
and we just did a new one for Harry
Potter the Boy Who Lived you can see all
the best moments right here we
hand-picked them Joe should we kill it
expect doughnuts roaster our next
roaster is a man you can always trust to
have you back because it's his favorite
place to stab Severus Snape mr. Potter
the only reason I haven't ended your
life yet is that I was in love with your
mother Lily do you remember when you
looked into my mind we both know what
you saw decades of me wanking it to your
mum your mother fills every vault in my
spank bank true depravity unlike that
which your feeble mind can conjure
sorted mental theatrics in which I
imagined taking her from behind in front
of the mirror of Erised said so your
father's ghost could watch deeply
penetrated her womb of Requirement huh
filling her puff as I slither in making
her rave and claw until she's Griffon
saw then hitting her in the face with a
hot load of etre nos when she doesn't
expect oh it you saw it butter and you
will never unsee it
Hagrid you fat piece of [ __ ] you're a
half giant half human and half ways of a
massive heart attack every year he
brings some new murderous creature to
school then act surprised when it does
something dangerous Oh blimey he didn't
mean to set the woods on fire he's just
a baby dragon Hagrid oh he didn't mean
to break the boy's armies just a
non-breaking basilisk think all the
books ended before he rescued a dagger
dick Traip wolf ball it's a rave wolf
won't have anyone to rape I guess I'll
give him a home near a school Hagrid is
so fat
his petronas is the Hamburglar agra you
look like Mumford if he ate all his sons
you look like every Vietnam veteran fuse
together Hagrid is sold fat the sorting
hat put him in the Waffle House what I'm
saying is your fat mate I'm not gonna
sugarcoat it or you try to eat that too
how does somebody who's been through so
much stay so [ __ ] boring they call you
the Boy Who Lived because the most
interesting thing about you is that you
are technically alive owns families so
pull that all the kids sleep in one room
which is tough on Ron when I'm your
sister I am Harry Potter hole play with
our man
with those jokes crazier than mad-eye
moody or what oh my god if you want to
watch the full uncensored uncut roast
you can watch it for free on screen
junkies plus when you sign up with
Facebook that's right register you can
watch it for free or if you're in the LA
area you could see a future roast by
clicking over here that's right be in
the area come check out a roast we're
going to do some fun stuff coming up
whether you like it or not hang out with
us
so click these boxes now we have to do
something stupid Joe can I pick your
nose no no no